Ich werde über das doppelte Vermächtnis
der Löwinnen-Theorie einer Petition sprechen.
Ist das im Hintergrund sehr gut hörbar, wenn
Sie sich mit Lebendigkeit beschäftigt haben,
nichts von dem, was ich zu sagen habe, wird Ihnen
unbekannt sein, es wurde alles
schon oft erklärt  Mein Beitrag in diesem
Fall ist also einfach der Versuch, das
Material so zu organisieren, dass der
Einfluss auf das spätere Denken und die
Reaktion darauf ziemlich sichtbar ist, also werde
ich das in drei Teile geteilte Papier behandeln,
zuerst das längste Material
zuerst  Ich werde über Leibniz über Kraft
und Appetit in Physik und Metaphysik
sprechen und dann ein wenig über Boo
Foams Reaktion darauf sagen
das wird bei U von L gezeichnet
und dann werde ich schließlich ein wenig
über Terry Marys und seine Erweiterungen und
Modifikationen in den Wäldern und
Höhen und seinem Buch über die schmutzige RIBA-
Ära von 1760 sagen  Obwohl er
jünger ist als zuvor, habe ich ihn hinterher gestellt,
weil er eindeutig auf vieles von dem reagiert,
was Bufo zu sagen hatte, also
beginnend mit Live Nets allgemeinen Merkmalen
der Löwinnen-Metaphysik
einerseits sind sie viele, viele Anwendungen des
Konzepts von Kraft und Appetit und  ein
Vokabular von Autonomie, Spontaneität und
Perfektionsfähigkeit, das für viele, viele
Bereiche des Diskurses gilt, Physik, Metaphysik,
Psychologie, Embryologie, andererseits
gibt es die Behauptung, dass individuelle
Schicksale und allgemeine Schicksale,
was mit der ganzen Welt geschehen wird,
von Gott bestimmt und für alle
Zeiten festgelegt wurden  die Wahl individueller
Substanzen, und im Gegensatz
zu all dem Vokabular von Autonomie und
Spontaneität gibt es auch eine Leugnung der Seele-Körper-
Interaktion und eine Behauptung von
Mechanismen, die eine effektive Leugnung
des freien Willens implizieren, obwohl sie kleine
Umwege versuchen, ein
Konzept von frei zu erklären  Will Goodin Generation
für Grenzen ist nur das mechanische
Wachstum eines vorgeformten und  präexistenter Organismus, der
keine besonderen formenden Kräfte hervorrufen muss
, also warum sagt das Licht nicht so
gut, dass er denkt, wenn Substanzen
nicht die Quellen ihrer eigenen Aktivität gewesen
wären, hätte Spinoza Recht gehabt, Gott
wäre die einzige Substanz im
Universum gewesen, die es getan hat  schlimme Folgen,
denkt er, und eine blinde fatale Notwendigkeit
hätte alles bestimmt, und er
sieht diese Bedrohung sogar in der kartesischen Physik,
auch wenn die Descartes
den freien Willen des Menschen zu verherrlichen schienen und die Meditationen
dort viel moralische Passivität und
Descartes leben mit Gedanken, die die
kartesische Metaphysik impliziert  dass Sie
nur warten, bis das nächste passiert,
gemäß der Vorsehung,
also warum hält er es für gut, nur
ein bisschen zu unterstützen?
Die Position des Herzens
zur Kausalität ist etwas unklar.
Er spricht manchmal davon, dass Körper
f besitzen  oder
Teile ihrer Geschwindigkeit aufeinander übertragen,
aber manchmal scheint er zu sprechen, als ob
Asoka gelegentlich das
Universum und verschiedene Konfigurationen
von Moment zu Moment neu erschaffen hat, aber in vielen
Passagen suggeriert er, dass in
Bewegung zu sein nicht bedeutet, von ihnen geschoben oder gezogen zu werden
eine Kraft, sondern nur um die eigene
Position relativ zu anderen Körpern zu ändern, und
es gibt eine Art übertriebene Version
davon in Melbridge. Melbridge entscheidet, dass
Gott der einzige aktive Agent im Universum ist, unter Androhung
des Götzendienstes
in der und in
dieser übertriebenen Version Gott nur
das Universum neu erschafft, gibt es keine
aktive Kraft in irgendetwas, nicht einmal im
menschlichen Willen, alles, was Gott
zusteht, also wird die Ähnlichkeit bestreiten, dass Melbridge sogar behauptet, niemand könne
seinen Arm alleine bewegen oder Gutes tun  oder böse oder
sprechen eine einzige Silbe, wir sind
bewegungslos und tot, es sei denn, Gott kommt
uns zu Hilfe und Spinoza behauptet, dass
Personen einschließlich p  ersons sind nur
Modi einer einzigen göttlichen Substanz, so dass
sie ihrer Lebendigkeit nach
keine substantielle Individualität selbst haben,
und das ist inakzeptabel,
aber gleichzeitig
gibt es in dieser frühneuzeitlichen Philosophie viele
Hinweise auf ein ganz anderes Bild
dessen, was passiert, Hinweise auf
conatus  Anstrengung, Streben und Teleologie
Die alte aristotelische Vorstellung, dass natürliche
Dinge für einen Zweck handeln müssen, belebte
und vielleicht sogar unbelebte Objekte müssen dies
tun und dass sichtbare Veränderung in der
Natur und Gesetzmäßigkeit Wirksamkeit
in einzelnen Dingen erfordert, so dass Hobbes, wie Sie sich
erinnern, Appetit und sogar Lust macht
konkurrierende und böswillige
Machtausübung zentral für seine politische
Anthropologie und Spinoza macht
trotz dieser Modi-Theorie und seines
Determinismus einen Drang nach
Selbsterhaltung und sogar Akkumulation
von Macht in allen individuellen Modi ziemlich
zentral für seine Anthropologie, so Appetit
im Jargon der spätscholastischen Physik
ist ein sehr etabliertes Konzept,
z  versucht, nicht nur die Anziehungskraft einer Sache
auf ihren natürlichen Platz in der
Kosmologie zu beschreiben, sondern auch den tierischen Appetit,
der in verschiedene Arten unterteilt ist, das
Begehren, die Reizbarkeit und den intellektuellen und
rationalen Appetit, oder wird dies tun,
indem er in seinem Aufsatz de ipsa Natura den Anlass angreift, listet Sturm auf,
anstatt ihn
anzugreifen  Melrose-Lebendigkeit war viel
freundlicher zu kalkzersetzenden Zysten, ganz
kanonisch für ihn, dass, wenn es Naturgesetze gibt,
Gott diese wirksam machen muss,
indem er eine Spur von
ihm in den Dingen zum Ausdruck bringt, muss eine
bestimmte Wirksamkeit in den Dingen eine
Form oder für
solche wie wir sein  normalerweise mit dem Namen
der Natur bezeichnen, aus der die Reihe der
Phänomene folgt, also eine sehr prägnante und
beredte Aussage darüber, dass Materie in der
lüsternen Metaphysik
nicht nur eine Erweiterung sein kann, da Descartes dachte,
es gäbe keine Quelle des Zusammenhalts.
Ich glaube nicht, Leibniz selbst  jemals
wirklich das Problem des Zusammenhalts gelöst oder sich
ernsthaft damit auseinandergesetzt, aber er hat
sich mit Rebound und Rebound befasst  Trägheit und Viswa
und entwickelte so eine ziemlich gut
artikulierte Theorie aktiver und passiver
Kräfte und Körper, beginnend mit der
kurzen Demonstration von 1684, in der er
zu zeigen versuchte, dass diese Viva
konserviert ist, und Experimente mit fallenden
Körpern, die Huygens nicht ursprünglich
hatte  dies vor Leibniz gezeigt hatte, aber er
hielt dies für einen schlüssigen Beweis dafür, dass
die cartesianische Theorie der Materie als reine
Erweiterung falsch sein musste,
man Kraft zuschreiben musste und es
nicht nur die Bewegungsgröße,
sondern die Kraft und später die
Kraftrichtung, die übereinstimmend erhalten bleiben musste  machte die
kartesische Theorie der Seele-Körper-
Interaktion physikalisch unmöglich, also
gibt es diese Leibniz-Ian-Adams der
Natur, die unkörperlich sind, also
unzerstörbar, also so ähnlich und
unsichtbar, weil sie unerschöpflich sind,
haben sie Erfahrungen und Begierden, und
irgendwie erfüllen sie die gleiche Funktion
wie körperliche Atome  Die
Systeme der korpuskularen Ameisen
erden irgendwie die Erscheinungen, aber es gibt einen
Weg  der Überwindung der Grenze zwischen
dem Unsichtbaren und Unverbrauchten
und dem Sichtbaren und Ausgedehnten, was
natürlich nicht erklärt wird,
so dass Lebendigkeit dachte, dass er und er
eine scholastische Vorstellung von
substantieller Form rehabilitierten, indem er Materie substantielle Form hinzufügte
, aber er behandelt Körper als
Phänomene, aber substantielle robuste
Phänomene  keine Illusionen, nicht wie der
Regenbogen, wie er sagt, und sie haben irgendeine
Art von aktiver und passiver Kraft, so dass es
auf diesen verschiedenen Ebenen
Analogien und Echos vorwärts strebender
Kräfte gibt, sehen Sie, das er behauptet, in der
Teleologie des kürzesten Weges sei sein bestes
Beispiel, dass es eine Premiere gibt  Zum Beispiel gibt
es Snells Gesetz, das besagt, dass in einem
Lichtstrahl, der von einem Medium zum
anderen wandert, der effizienteste Weg genommen wird,
das gleiche Konzept, von dem er glaubt, dass es
im Appetit der unsichtbaren Monaden vorhanden ist
, die zu ihrer nächsten Wahrnehmung gezogen werden,
wir sehen es im Appetit Verlangen  und wird in
lebenden Organismen im
Entwicklungsimpuls in Samen die Puppe der
Larve in der  Entwicklung der
Samentierchen wir sehen es in der
Entwicklungsfortschrittsbewegung in der
moralischen Welt, in der es mehr
Aufklärung, mehr Wissenschaft, mehr Kultur,
mehr Gerechtigkeit gibt, dies wird in der
Theodizee diskutiert und in der Art und Weise, wie der
Geist nach
kleinen Erschütterungen und Störungen nach Gleichgewicht strebt  spricht
darüber in den neuen Essays und in der
Art und Weise, wie in einigen der
esoterischeren Schriften die möglichen
Substanzen danach streben, tatsächlich zu werden, und auf
diese Weise hat die Welt
mögliche Substanzen im Geist Gottes geformt, der
zusammen mit dem
So-Alles darum kämpft, zu existieren  Lebewesen
nach den Texten von 6090 haben nicht nur
einen Körper, sondern auch eine Seele und diese Behauptung wird
in den neuen Aufsätzen aufrechterhalten. Es gibt eine
Wahrnehmung und eine Bitte sogar in
Pflanzen, was Lebendigkeit betrifft,
wegen der Analogie, die zwischen Pflanzen
und Tieren besteht und  menschliches glück ist
immer ein kampf. ruhe ist ein
schwer fassbares ideal, wie auch hobbes behauptet,
in dem in ruhe nichts ist
In der Erörterung von
Lockes Doktrin des Unbehagens, für die
Leibniz sehr sympathisch ist,
beschreibt Leibniz diese Tendenz von
Geist und Körper, ein gestörtes
Gleichgewicht wiederherzustellen, das wie ein Pendel ist
Eine Uhr ist gestört, aber sie versucht,
sich wiederherzustellen. Unsere Impulse sind wie so
viele kleine Quellen, die wir versuchen, uns zu
lösen und unsere Maschine zum
Laufen zu bringen, aber gleichzeitig mit all
diesen Bildern von Aktivität und Spontaneität
und Vorwärtsbewegung und ihren
Einschränkungen und  Qualifikationen,
die Leibniz sicherlich zu einem etwas
altmodischen mechanischen Philosophen des 18. Jahrhunderts machen,
so dass er
behauptet, dass die korpuskulare
e'en kartesische Physik sogar die aufsteigenden
Bezirke mechanischer Wechselwirkungen
grundsätzlich theoretisch für alle
Tiere, Menschen und menschliche Physiologie angemessen ist, gibt
es kein Okkultes  Kräfte, die in der Physik zulässig sind,
einschließlich Anziehung und bei einem
An dieser Stelle akzeptiert er irgendwie
glücklicherweise die Newtonsche Darstellung der
universellen Anziehung als Rettung der
kosmologischen Phänomene, aber solange sie
lediglich die Erscheinungen und diese
Art der Vorhersage von Dingen regelt,
anstatt ontologischer II grundlegender Art, gibt es
keine Geist-Körper-Interaktion, nur die
Prä-  etablierte Harmonie einer doppelten
Reihe mechanisch
erklärbarer und vorhersagbarer physiologischer Ereignisse und einer
Reihe mentaler Ereignisse, der Wunsch und die
Wahrnehmung, all dies impliziert Gottes
Wahl der individuellen Substanz, so dass
es eine totale Vorhersagbarkeit der
Zukunft gibt, einschließlich menschlicher Handlungen im
Prinzip und in gewisser Weise  Interessante
Passage Lebendigkeit besagt, dass eine Person, eine
menschliche Person, eine Maschine bauen könnte, die
in der Lage wäre, eine
Zeit lang durch die Stadt zu gehen und genau an den
Ecken bestimmter Straßen abzubiegen, und
ein vollkommenerer Geist, noch ein begrenzter Geist,
muss kein Gott sein  könnte eine
Maschine bauen, die eine
weitaus größere Anzahl von Hindernissen vorhersehen und vermeiden
würde, und das sagt er  Wenn die Welt so wäre, wie einige
denken, dass sie nur eine Kombination aus einer
endlichen Anzahl von Atomen ist, die interagieren
und mit mechanischen Gesetzen übereinstimmen, ist es
sicher, dass ein endlicher Verstand alles
verstehen und mit Sicherheit vorhersagen könnte
, was in einer bestimmten Periode passieren wird,
es ist wirklich eine ziemliche
außergewöhnlicher Gedanke, denn Leibniz
scheint die Möglichkeit
als Backup in Erwägung zu ziehen, dass die Welt vielleicht nur
eine Kombination von Atomen ist, die von materiellen
wie mechanischen Gesetzen beherrscht werden, was natürlich
völlig im Widerspruch zu seiner offiziellen
Metaphysik steht, also
der angeblichen Spontaneität von Substanzen,
ihrer Autonomie und Freiheit von
Bestimmung durch äußere Reize
entpuppt sich
zumindest beim Nachdenken
über Willensfreiheit und die Wirksamkeit von Entscheidungen als
eine Art Trick
Äußeres Wesen oder Gewalt alles,
was einer Substanz widerfährt, ist eine
Folge ihres Begriffs oder ihres Bu-Seins  t Sie
können nicht von Ihrem eigenen vorherbestimmten Drehbuch abweichen,
wenn es um die
Trennung zwischen
Mensch und Tier
geht  für alle Pflanzen wie auch für
alle Tiere, weil Seelen
immer in Verbindung mit Körpern und
Abbildern gefunden werden, ist das Konto von Tod und
Unsterblichkeit nur, dass die
Seele an einem sehr, sehr kleinen
Teil der Materie auf die gleiche Weise
haftet, wie sie zuvor gebunden war  Geburt und eines Tages kann
dieser sehr kleine Teil der Materie
wieder zu einem vollständigen Organismus heranwachsen, aber
das wird von der Philosophie nicht garantiert, und
die Menschen handeln wie die Bestien, da sie
in drei Vierteln ihrer Handlungen einfach empirisch sind,
so dass im Gegensatz dazu eine gewisse Betonung auf der
Mensch-Tier-Kontinuität liegt
In der kartesischen Tradition
hingegen wird viel Wert auf
Diskontinuität gelegt, die nur Menschen als notwendig
und ewig kennen  Wahrheiten nur Menschen reflektieren
sich
selbst haben Selbstbewusstsein unsere
Wahrnehmung und Erkenntnis von Gott nur
Menschen verstehen Gottes Werke durch
Wissenschaft und Menschen haben eine schöpferische Kraft
, die Gottes analog ist unsere Seele ist
wie ein Architekt in ihren freiwilligen
Handlungen und auch in ihren unfreiwilligen
Aktionen sein Erfindungsreichtum in Träumen Limette
erwähnt dies nur und an manchen
Stellen im Traum erfinden wir mühelos
Dinge, über die man im Wachzustand lange grübeln müsste,
heißt es im
Traum und vielleicht hat er kurz vor dem
Einschlafen diese Visionen von
komplizierter Architektur  was wir heute
als hypnagogische Bilder betrachten, die
tatsächlich phantastisch geometrisch sein können, und
das war offensichtlich ein
auffälliges psychologisches Phänomen für
ihn, also unterscheidet uns das Wissen um ewige und
notwendige Wahrheiten
vom Rest der Tiere, und das ist es, was
die rationale Seele ist  handlungsfähige
und fensterlose Nester für lebende Listen
metaphysisch einzelner Substanzen
interagieren nicht, also können sie sich nicht gegenseitig beschädigen oder
zerstören, und selbst auf
empirischer Ebene gibt es fast das Gefühl,
dass lebende Individuen
nicht miteinander interagieren, aber
sie werden nicht explizit als solche theoretisiert
, wenn Sie also an die Lyme-Borreliose denken
Bilder von Lebewesen sind wirklich
ganz anders als „Herzen nehmen“, erinnerst du dich
? Ich nehme Herzen. Diskussion über
die Schafe und den Wolf
in der Abhandlung von
ihnen  Impulse vom Wolf
wirken auf das Schafauge, die
Ventile im Gehirn öffnen und als Ergebnis
bewegen sich die Beine des Schafs und es rennt
gut davon. Wir haben eine klare Interaktion zwischen
zwei Organismen und in Live-Tänzen lebende
Weltbilder haben wir Fische,
in denen wir herumschwimmen  ein Teich und im Wasser
zwischen den Fischen ist es auch voller
Organismen und im Wasser zwischen diesen
kleineren Organismen gibt es noch
kleinere, aber sie scheinen alle nur
undi herumzuschwimmen  von allen
anderen für immer gestört, bis Gott
sie in ihren kleinen Räumen vernichtet,
anstatt anzugreifen, zu verdrängen
und solche Dinge zu tun, so dass in der
kartesischen Welt der Schafe und der
Wolf in einer
anspruchsvollen und gefährlichen Welt ums Überleben kämpfen und mit denen
sie ausgestattet waren  eine Reihe eingebauter
automatischer Reaktionen zur Erhaltung ihres
völlig bedingten Lebens. Ich glaube, ich sehe,
wo ich bin, oh gut, also auf eine aufgeblasene
Erweiterung und Überarbeitung dieser allgemeinen
Haftungsinfektion 17, 49 bis 54, die
eine Periode der ersten drei Bände
der Naturgeschichte ist  und seine Übersetzung
ins Deutsche 17:51 davor hat zahlreiche
Hinweise auf den Schöpfer, aber der
Schöpfer könnte genauso gut die Natur sein
Wissen stammt nur aus dem Studium der
Phänomene, es bedarf absolut keiner
rationalistischen Metaphysik, aus Poofles
Sicht ist die Natur chaotisch ein weites Feld von
Harmonien  und Disharmonien und
erkennt den Ausbau
wissenschaftlich seriöser Resident
Powers vor  und Kräfte Anziehungskräfte Elektrizität
Magnetismus und
andere durchdringende Kräfte, die
auf die gesamte Substanz von Körpern einwirken Warum
sollten wir sie ablehnen, sagt er, solange
wir tatsächliche Erfahrung mit den Wirkungen haben,
die sie hervorrufen, warum
nur die Kraft des Antriebs anwenden Die Natur ist a
lebendige Kraft unermesslich
alles umarmend alles belebend ein Werk
ewig lebendig Zeit Raum und Materie
sind ihre Mittel widerfahren sagt das Universum
ihr Objekt Bewegung und Leben ihr Zweck
[Applaus]
und wenn es um das Leben Geist und
Materie geht, gibt es eine dualistische Ontologie
unzerstörbarer Einheiten von Brute  Materie und
unzerstörbare Einheiten lebender Materie
Tiere Ich werde Tiere nur
für nicht-menschliche Tiere verwenden. Tiere halten es
einfach. Tiere sind rein materielle
Wesen, an die keine Seele gebunden
ist  als eine Reihe
von Funktionen haben und nicht als eine Sache, und
es gibt absolut keine Diskussion
irgendwo in der Naturgeschichte  der
Unsterblichkeit wenig Zugeständnis an die
Sorbonne, die etliche Thesen kritisiert hatte
und doch die übliche Beschäftigung
der Philosophen mit der Unsterblichkeit
der Seele völlig fehlt und Bufo
trotz der oberflächlichen Ähnlichkeit des Menschen
mit dem Affen auch in Bezug auf
sein Gehirn den Menschen sagt
hat zwar eine Seele,
aber er versucht nie, den
Unterschied zwischen Affe und Mensch
mit einer darin implantierten körperlosen Substanz zu erklären
, und sie deutet wirklich an,
dass es vielleicht einen unsichtbaren
Unterschied zwischen dem Gehirn des Affen und
dem Gehirn des Menschen gibt
Alle Fähigkeiten, die Menschen haben, sind
vielleicht einfach zu klein, um gesehen zu werden, weil
wir keinen Unterschied in den
Gehirnen von Idioten und normalen Menschen
auf der Mensch-Tier-Grenze sehen. Performa
sagt, die Tiere haben Empfindungen und
Erfahrungen, aber sie haben keine  reflektieren
Ideen vergleichen Pläne für die Zukunft sich
erinnern oder begründen, dass er sogar sagt, dass sie
ihre Träume nicht von der Realität unterscheiden können,
was auch immer t  Sie haben geträumt, dass aus ihrer
Sicht tatsächlich etwas sehr Unglaubliches passiert ist und sie ein
komplexes Verhalten gezeigt haben, aber dies wird
durch rein materielle
Mechanismen erreicht. Sie sind Automaten, die von
einer Lebenskraft belebt werden, und wie ich bereits erwähnte, ist der
Affe ähnlich, obwohl es ihn gibt
tiefgreifende Unterschiede in Fähigkeiten
und Temperament, so dass das unbewegliche,
bewusstlose schlafende Tier wie die
Auster eine relativ einfache Maschine ist,
und aber jedes Tier, das sich bewegen kann,
Erfahrungen mit Begierden macht, und das scheint
eine Aufnahme der Live-Distanz-Vorstellung einer
Petition zu sein, und Erfahrungen entstehen aus dem
Zustand  von der materiellen Maschine kann dies nicht
so erklärt werden, dass ich
mich selbst nicht sehen kann oder der Finger sich nicht
berühren kann, der Verstand nicht erklären kann, wie
es dazu kommt, Erfahrungen und
Wünsche zu haben, sie sind jedoch vollkommen in der
Lage  aus der maschine entstehen
die tiere erfinden nichts sie perfektionieren
nichts sie machen immer das gleiche auf
die gleiche art die alte cartesia  n Anspruch und
der schon vorher sagt, wir haben keine
Instinkte, ihre Aufmerksamkeit für ihre
Nachkommen folgt aus Vertrautheit mit
ihnen, mit anderen Worten, alles folgt
entweder aus Lernen oder aus
mechanisch eingebauten Mustern, die er
nicht als Instinkt betrachten will, und das
obwohl Elefanten, Affen und Biber
Affen haben ein komplexes soziales Verhalten,
suchen einander, versammeln sich,
bewegen sich in Truppen, kümmern sich umeinander.
Ihre Gesellschaften hängen wie die Bienen
nur von universellen Mechanismen und
Bewegungsgesetzen ab, die von ihrem Schöpfer festgelegt wurden
Domestizierung von Tieren
argumentiert vor, dass die anderen Tiere
durch Domestizierung degradiert worden sind,
sie haben ihre primitiven Fähigkeiten verloren
und dies ist sogar bei wilden Tieren passiert,
mit Haustieren müssen wir
zwischen dem Geschöpf Gottes
mit seinen Instinkten unterscheiden, da scheint er zu
akzeptieren  Instinkte und die versklavten
Tiere unterworfen  Unsere Zucht und
Ausbildung, aber auch viele wilde Arten
haben ihre natürlichen Talente verloren. Die
Biber, sagt er, scheinen eine
Spur der uralten Intelligenz
der Tiere bewahrt zu
haben  sagt, wenn Sie, wenn eine Person
ein Objekt erreichen wollte und sich
schmerzlos beraubt fand, vermutlich, wenn Sie ihre
Gliedmaßen wegnahmen, ihre Beine, sie
versuchten, es mit ihren Armen zu bekommen, Sie
ihnen wegnahmen, ihre Arme
wegnahmen, sie sich irgendwie darauf zu winden
ein Mensch würde sich an seinem Kinn
oder seinen Zähnen schleppen, selbst wenn wir seinen Körper
auf die Größe eines physischen Punkts eines Atoms reduzieren,
wenn der Wunsch noch vorhanden ist, wird er
alle seine Kräfte aufwenden, um seine Position so zu ändern,
dass die Remoras Erweiterungen und
Abweichungen von Grund  Lebe mit Sein
Dichotomie und meinen Maras, wie du weißt, ist er ein
scharfer Kritiker des Christentums sowohl des
Alten als auch des Neuen Testaments, aber er ist auch ein
Kritiker des epikureischen Materialismus
als solcher  Präsentiert von Lama Tree Moco Chewy and
Befall Sein Projekt besteht darin, die
besondere und von der Vorsehung geschaffene Schöpfung von
Tieren zu verteidigen, und das Mittel dazu besteht darin, zu
argumentieren, dass postnatales Lernen nicht
ausreicht, um die Bandbreite und
Komplexität von Arten zu erklären, die das Verhalten von Tieren aufrechterhalten,
und sie hat drei allgemeine  von Reba
das ist alles sehr schön erklärt in
Nizza Johnsons aktuellem Buch
über Physiologie und Life Science so
gibt's das jetzt wie Stricken
Darstellungen fakultät geworden ist bei
Reva die vier Shilling Trevor das ist
ein Antrieb der Welt bewusst zu sein und zu werden
der Zustand des eigenen Körpers seitens
des Tieres und da ist der böse Kariba-
Appetit das Streben nach Lust und
Befriedigung, das das Tier antreibt
und dann gibt es noch eine ganze Reihe von
Kunst-RIBA-Tierfähigkeiten Graben
Nestbau
Balz Elternschaft und Migration,
die das unterstützen  Tiere harmonisch und
fortbestehen und die Mächte der
Materie, sagt Rui Morris dagegen
könnte nie widerfahren  r erklären die Triva vor allem
die Strömungen Raben und Löwinnen
prästabilierte Harmonie ist inakzeptabel
tierische Erfahrung und Motivation
zusammen mit göttlich eingepflanztem
Instinkt bewirkt tierisches Verhalten es
gibt dennoch einige Anklänge an Romo
Alfred Leibniz in Reim Aras die
Welt besteht seiner Meinung nach ausschließlich aus Kräften die
handeln  darin werden die widersprüchlichen Kräfte
Gott sei Dank zur Deckung gebracht und
gegen Buffon harmonisiert alle Tiere
sind in Seelen sie haben Ideen Vorstellung
und Erinnerung wieder vor und alle
Tiere haben ein
durch ihre natürlichen Kräfte erreichbares inneres Ziel durch Leibniz
und Teleologie wieder aber nur  Menschliche
Fähigkeiten werden mit Intelligenz geübt
und ermöglichen Innovation, da es ihnen an Reflexion
und Sprache mangelt. Die anderen Tiere können
Kunst, Wissenschaft und Moral nicht untersuchen,
was so ziemlich
der universelle Konsens ist, also etwas
hier oben und anhaltende Kontroversen des
doppelten Erbes, die alle von diskutiert
werden können.  t ähm zuerst, was nicht mechanisch
f  Zum Beispiel kann ein Gebäude Sweep
in die Wissenschaft erlaubt werden, um Morphologie zu erklären.
Generation. Zweitens
können all
jene Naturkräfte,
die in Materie zu wirken schienen, aber nicht
direkt wahrgenommen werden können, philosophisch, wenn nicht sogar empirisch nachgewiesen werden
Ursache, wie sie drittens gefolgert werden müssen,
ist die Welt harmonisch und gestaltet oder
könnte ein materialistisches epikureisches System des
Untergangs mit der Natur sein, das durch Versuch
und Irrtum an zufälligen Kombinationen arbeitet,
erklärte Anpassungen, dass die adaptiven
Wesen nur diejenigen sind, die
nach allen anderen übrig bleiben  scheiterte
und sogar die Existenz von sich selbst
reproduzierenden Organismen könnte das nur
eine Frage erfolgreicher Kombinationen
sein, die sich nun
als die vernünftigste
Alternative zur Theorie der
prästabilierten Harmonie von Körper und Seele
herausstellten  eine Art Influx-Theorie oder oder was
und schließlich, ob alles Verhalten, einschließlich des
menschlichen Verhaltens, kausal ist  y bestimmt
und im Prinzip vorhersehbar, was
die Folgen für Recht und Moral sind, die
große Sorge der Katzen, aber damit werde
ich dort enden, vielen Dank